right ted says tomorrow will be a better  day to spend some time outside with the  kids it's also kids to park day a  national movement on the third saturday  of may each year encouraging outdoor  play research shows that can improve  both physical and mental health in our  kids there's a whole lot less myopia for  kids who play outside that's that  nearsightedness then kids who play  inside or look at screens a lot there's  all these mental and emotional health  things less anger and aggression  better  learning outcomes for kids who are  playing outside more  of course you don't even have to go far  just get out enjoy nature in the  backyard or at the playground  all right kiwi